اهلا بكم الى هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
على مختلف الصعود سينضم الينا من اوسلو
الدكتور ماس جلبرت رئيس الفريق الطبي
النرويجي الى قطاع غزه وسنس الضوء على
واقع القطاع الطبي في غزه بعد مرور اكثر
من 100 يوم على العدوان الاسرائيلي ونشير
في البدايه الى ما اعلنته وزاره الصحه في
غزه بان عدد الشهداء قد ارتفع الى
2497 منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي في حين
بلغ عدد الجرحى
و388 مصابا منذ بدايه العدوان وقد اشارت
الوزاره كذلك الى ان
70% من ضحايا الحرب الاسرائيليه هم اطفال
ونساء وقال المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي ان
هناك 7000 مفقود تحت الانقاض او ممن يعتبر
مصيرهم
مجهولا
وبالارقام
تظهر الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه ضد القطاع
الطبي في غزه استشهاد
337 كادرا صحيا منذ بدايه الع عدوان في
السابع من اكتوبر الماضي كذلك اعتقال
99 من موظفي القطاع الطبي على راسهم
مديروا مستشفيات شمال
غزه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تعمد استهداف
150 مؤسسه صحيه في القطاع وكذلك تعمد خروج
30 مستشفى و
53 مركزا صحيا عن الخدمه كذلك استهداف
122 سياره اسعاف من قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي دمرت تماما
350 الف مريض بامراض مزمنه قد يتعرضون
لمضاعفات صحيه خطيره وذلك نتيجه عدم دخول
الادويه لقطاع غزه 10000 مريض بالسرطان
يتعرضون لمضاعفات نتيجه انعدام الرعايه
الصحيه في اماكن النزوح وذلك بعد خروج
مستشفى الصداقه التركي عن
الخدمه
8000 اصابه بعدوى التهابات الكبد الوبائي
الفيروسي نتيجه الاكتظاظ في اماكن
النزوح اذا بعد كل هذه الارقام القاسيه
والمؤلمه ينضم الان الينا من اصل الدكتور
ماس جلبرت رئيس الفريق الطبي النرويجي الى
قطاع غزه دكتور جلبرت ليست المره الاولى
التي
نلتقيك في المره السابقه تحدثت بالم كبير
وبحرقه ولكن الارقام زادت بشكل مخيف ما
تقييمك لما
سمعت مع الاسف فعلا هذه
الارقام تبين لنا بان القتل الصناعي
واستهداف الفلسطيني من قبل جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يستمر وهذه الارقام مروعه
وانها تقتل كمعدل 200 الى 240 شخصا يوميا
وتجرح حوالي 400 شخص يوميا وهذا طبعا هلا
يحتاجون الى نظام الرعايه الصحيه الذي
يتعرض بدوره للهجوم من قبل قوات الاحتلال
اذا لدينا فقدان التوازن هذا هناك
احتياجات الرعايه الصحيه وقدرات النظام
الصحي و لحد الان فقط 11 فريقا اجنبيا
طبيا سمح لهم
بالدخول وكلهم سويه في الجنوب في رفح معظم
الوقف والمستشفى الاوروبي اما في شمال غزه
فتقريبا لا
شيء وبجب نظام الصحه
العالميه ان 15 من 36 مستشفى في غزه تعمل
جزئيا وهذا خبر سيء وكذلك خبر سيء اخر هو
هناك امراض وبائيه تنتشر متزايد واخر
تقرير جاء وزاره الصحه الغزاويه بان هناك
8000 حاله من التهاب الكبد الوبائي وهذا
الرقم سيتضاعف في المستقبل القريب هذه
كارثه بذاتها هذا تطور بالنسبه
للاجئين والنازحين قصرا هناك حوالي اكثر
من مليون شخص الان يتعرضون لتعرض الى هذذه
الامراض المعديه وعلى الارجح هذه الامراض
ستقتل اعداد من ناس اكثر ما تقتل القنابل
فان خ مزيج المجاعه وقله الماء وانتشار
الاوبئه في الايام الاسابيع القادمه ستقتل
مزيد من الفلسطين اكثر ما يقتلون في القنا
والشيء دكتور جيلبرت دعني اقاطعك اعرف انك
يعني تعرف وكنت على تواصل مباشر مع كثير
من الاطباء وكثير من الكوادر الطبيه في
غزه لانك عملت الى جانبهم وكنت من الذين
رفعوا الصوت عاليا منذ البدايه واسالك
الان هل كانت هناك استجابه حقيقيه هل
لاحظت اي تغيير في نوع الدعم الذي تحظى به
الكوادر الطبيه اليوم في داخل القطاع هل
هناك مساعدات جاده اكثر مما سبق
اليوم هذا سؤال وجيه واعتقد ان لدينا
علينا ان نظل جانبين على الارض في كل دول
العالم هنا هناك زياده كبيره في الدعم
الشعبي للعاملين في الجال الصحي من
الفلسطينين وطلب هناك طلب متزايد لايقاف
القصف فورا وايقاف حصار غزه هذا الطلب
يتزايد لكن من جانب اخر الحكومات تقوم بلا
شيء تقريبا وخاصه الحكومات اوروبيه وقد
شاهدنا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه ان بعض
الحكومات بدا تحدث بشكل اكثر حول فتح
ابواب غزه وادخال مزيد مساعدات الانسانيه
لكن ما نحتاجه حاليا هو وقف فوري للقصف
وهذا ينبغي ان يكون نتيجه ضغوط كبيره
باجراءات اكثر من حركات التضامن وانا اعلم
كل العالم ان العاملين في المجال الصحي
زملائي طلبه واطباء كلهم كلهم يحاولون ان
ي ضغوطا سياسيه على الحكومات المختلفه
لايقاف الهجمات هل هناك ما يمنع من توجههم
بالفعل الى القطاع في هذه الفتره يعني هل
هو هل هناك منع للفرق الطبيه بعيدا عن
استجابه
الحكومات اعتقد الشيئان لابد الاجابه
علمها بكلمه نعم فاسرائيل هي التي سيطر
سيطره قويه على رفح والمعبر
الاخر وهم قد وضعوا قائمه
اسماء لابد ان يوافق على تشكيله كل فريق
طبي وكما قلت فقط احد
فريقا بجام صغير باعداد سمح لتلون بالدخول
وبالتالي لابد منكك ضغط من قبل على
الولايات المتحده لفتح معبر فتح والسماح
لادخال المساعدات الانسانيه واهم شيء هنا
هو
العم دعم النظام الصحي الفلسطيني وقد تلقت
اتصال من الدكتور مروان ابو سعيد الذي هو
يعمل في مستشفى الشفاء من مره اخرى الخبر
الجيد ان مستشفى بدا ينفتح تدريجيا بعض
الخدمات الطبيه بفضل عمل الجريء لعمال
الطبيين الفلسطينيين الكوادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه ورغم كل ما تعرضت له ما زالت
في الميدان اذا دكتور ماس جلبرت رئيس
الفريق الطبي النرويجي الى قطاع غزه نشكرك
على وجودك مع معنا ونتمنى فعلا ان تثمر كل
مناشدات وجهودك ختام هذه النافذه
الانسانيه نعود الى غرفه الاخبار لمتابعه
اخر التطورات